scale of one to ten
how stunned were you by the news today
that the guy who started just yesterday
for washington at quarterback dwayne
haskins has been cut by the team
yeah 10 or 11 mike i mean you just don't
see anything like this right
one year into after they drafted him
15th overall i was stunned and i just
didn't see this coming despite
everything that's happened it was
stunning
yeah we have
a thread that we exchange where all of
the pft writers say well i'm going to
write this story i'm going to get this
story that's how we keep from crossing
streams a lot of ghostbusters and every
once in a while there's one that makes
us all go wow and that was one that made
us go wow and here's the statement from
coach ron rivera this afternoon i met
with dwayne and informed him that we
would be releasing him i told him that i
believe it benefits both parties that we
go our separate ways we want to thank
dwayne for his contributions these last
two seasons and wish him well moving
forward i'm impressed that i was able to
see all that because
i'm a little bit too old and my eyes
aren't as good as they used to be
although i pass
the test every time i go back for my
driver's license just so the record is
clear i do not read need corrective
lenses yet uh uh it it uh
you know my understanding is
that between what happened last week
with the covet 19 escapades they find
him forty thousand dollar sharing they
took away his captaincy
but whatever went down yesterday and i
don't know that we're ever gonna know
this but i think some stuff went down
yesterday when he tried to skip out on
the media obligations and they basically
dragged him back in by his ear and made
him do it like my mom used to drag me
around by my ear and make me do things i
didn't want to do
that something went down within the
confines of all of that i believe that
prompted them to say enough because he
started the game yesterday so something
between the ending of the game or
whenever he was benched in the game and
today made them say that's it we're done
take your 10 million plus we've already
paid you and we may have to pay you
another 4.2 million over the next two
years and guaranteed salary we don't
care just get the hell out of here
completely agree with you mike and that
was going to be my point i think
something happened after that game at
minimum he left the stadium very quickly
after the game we do know that i mean
that's basically verified because they
couldn't they
pr couldn't get him right after the game
he was gone he had left the stadium they
called him he didn't answer his phone
they finally got a hold of him and he
did end up doing his uh media obligation
which is required under the media access
policy so he did end up doing it but
something transpired there and even if
it was as little as leaving the stadium
you remember the one time vince young
walked out with his jersey and his
shoulder pads and everything else on and
went home maybe it was something like
that but whatever happened something
transpired after that game that
washington said enough is enough we are
absolutely done we told you last week
this was your last chance and you didn't
take advantage of it
yeah and there's a story to be told out
there and maybe someday we will have the
information to fill in the gap but
something did go down and now he is gone
and there could be a fight over this 4.2
million dollars i laid out what the
washington football team would need to
say
in
the official paperwork to position
itself to potentially potentially avoid
the 4.2 million remember the and boy it
seems like a long time ago the earl
thomas case with the ravens guaranteed
money isn't completely and totally
guaranteed no matter what it's
guaranteed for skill injury and salary
cap you can cut someone
for personal conduct detrimental to the
team there's a specific language
personal contract adverse to the
interest of the team's best interest
something like that there's magic words
that you say and if you cut the player
for that reason if you can prove that's
the reason and that's just not not a
pretext for skill injury or cap then you
can argue the guarantee
does not apply and also i looked at the
language of his contract they could
argue that some of the stuff that's gone
down over the past week
invalidates the guarantee for the next
4.2 million and look it's 4.2 million
even for a billionaire it's 4.2 million
and we've learned
recently if we didn't already know
daniel snyder the owner of the team a
little bit litigious why not say you'll
get nothing and like it and force dwayne
haskins to come try to get the money if
they believe there's a basis for saying
you did something wrong and sharing the
guys publicly apologized multiple times
that may be all they need to show that
he did something he shouldn't have done
why are you issuing all these apologies
if you're not doing things you shouldn't
have done
yeah i have no question that dan snyder
likely will go after that money just
based on other things that dan snyder
has done we know dan snyder is dan
snyder and this was his hand-picked guy
mike he he wanted dwayne haskins and the
coaching staff and scouting department
by all accounts was not on board with
this and if you're not on board if
you're coaching staff now this is a
different coaching staff i understand
but if your coaching staff and your
scouting
staff isn't on board with a draft pick
it's probably not going to work out we
saw the same thing happen with jamarcus
russell al davis hand-picked guy we saw
the same thing with vince young was but
adam's saying hand-picked guy it didn't
work out for any of those guys
especially at the quarterback position
the coach and the staff have to be on
board with that pick
and obviously they were not on board and
the new staff tried to try to make this
work and they couldn't make it work
either
yeah and uh you know there were the
efforts by ron rivera early in the off
season when he got the job and and i
thought it was a little bit of the
effort to coax a greater level of
commitment dwayne haskins reshaped his
body i saw pictures of him when he got
to training camp he looked nothing like
he did last year he was committed he
just wasn't any better and he had a
chance and it didn't work and some
other thing happened to cause him to
plummet all the way to number three on
the depth chart and he was just done and
then they needed him and he had a chance
again and it didn't work and the strip
club thing had to be the last straw and
let's just get through the season and
figure it out i think that was the
decision that they made
last week common sense would suggest
they just said let's get through the
season and then we'll figure out what
we're going to do with this guy and they
still could have just
carried him on the roster this week
deactivate him for the game against the
eagles on sunday night if they make it
to the playoffs deactivate them for
those games and then decide whether or
not there's some sort of a trade market
and
here's the reality shireen one of the
big sunday splash stories for week 16
was this notion that multiple franchises
are doing their homework on urban meyer
the former ohio state coach who coached
dwayne haskins if he gets one of these
jobs maybe you could trade dwayne
haskins to the lions the jaguars or
wherever it is that dwayne or that urban
meyer is going to land although the
jaguars wouldn't make a whole lot of
sense if he goes there because they're
going to get trevor lawrence now
congratulations the tank worked but but
i am a little surprised at this stage of
the season with just one game left they
didn't kick the can unless the the
message
was more important to be sent to the
locker room it's possible the guys in
the locker room
had enough
and this is the kind of thing that maybe
galvanizes the team with a playoff
play-in game coming up on sunday night
which is why you go back to something
happening after that game mike because
it does make sense that they would try
to trade him in the offseason and do
what the cardinals did with josh rosen
send him to miami at least you get
something for him they are getting
nothing for dwayne haskins and you know
speaking of urban meyer ron rivera
called urban meyer before the year
started and said how do we get you know
to this guy and he said he said look he
only started 14 games in college you
have to be patient with him but he
responds to challenge so that's what ron
rivera tried to do we remember in the
off season he talked about dwayne
haskins has got to be a better leader i
don't know if he's going to be our
starting quarterback all those things he
said and then after he was benched in
week four haskins ron rivera said we
need to see better preparedness from
this quarterback we don't like the way
he's preparing challenged him again and
every time they've challenged him he has
failed that challenge so urban meyer
probably is his best chance to get a
second chance or a third chance or a
fourth chance or whatever chance dwayne
haskins is on in the nfl right now mike
and i really thought dwayne haskins was
going to perform better now he came into
the nfl young he left with two years
remaining of eligibility in college and
it could be he's just a little bit raw
he's a little immature look as my son
has progressed through 20 21 22 and i've
seen him grow and mature and i've
thought back to how he was a couple of
years ago i can see in a lot of these
young nfl players the way he was you're
finding your way and it's difficult it's
challenging you throw 10 million in
guarantees no 14 million but 10 million
in cash over two seasons into their
pockets into their bank accounts and
it's it's it's a lot to process the
stress and the pressure of being a
starting quarterback the social media
criticism it's relentless so
there's still room for dwayne haskins to
grow and i think he's got potential he
just needs to have an opportunity to
grow in a setting where there isn't a
sense of entitlement remember last week
when we were having this conversation i
said it was a combination of immaturity
stupidity and the entitlement that comes
from having a guaranteed contract
because the attitude is what are you
going to do cut me well yeah we did and
yeah this this isn't quite apples to
apples the old chris carter buddy ryan
all he does is catch touchdowns and they
cut him to give him the wake-up call
that that worked it propelled him to the
hall of fame in minnesota but this could
be the thing that ultimately
helps dwayne haskins career if he means
it when he apologizes if this isn't just
something that was written by a pr
flunky and he was told tweet this from
your account if he really means that if
he really believes it maybe this is what
he needs to turn it around humble
himself go fight and compete and scratch
and claw and wait for an opportunity and
make the most of it when it comes your
way he needs to become a student of the
game he needs to become serious about
learning the nfl way and maybe there's a
chance for him to turn it around shereen
mike he's got the apologies down and it
so much reminds me of johnny manziel and
you know i love johnny manziel he did
great things at texas a m but every time
he screwed up he sounded so sincere i'm
gonna take advantage of this second
chance you know i've been given a second
chance i did wrong i'm remorseful i
apologize
dwayne haskins has said those same words
and he's been convincing i mean i
watched it last night after his
a game that was so bad i watched him
talk and he sounded so convincing i'm
going to take advantage of this second
chance and and he said it earlier in the
week and he said it earlier this season
when he had a coveted violation and
every time he says it he he sounds like
he means it and then he has to say it
again and again and again and now we've
heard it three or four times and it's
really losing its luster at this point
mike
yeah and it makes me wonder
does he just not mean it or can he not
help it and either way look he's young
the brain is still developing for people
in their early twenties he's not the man
he's eventually going to be and these
experiences hopefully will help guide
him toward becoming the man that he will
be he has the talent that's undeniable
the question is what do you do with it
and when and where can you find someone
who will trust you with
not a starting job for now with a spot
on the depth chart and urban meyer may
be the best ticket for
dwayne haskins
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports